[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news I'm
Heather Bruce into mio no wave and this
is your news for Monday March 12th first
of all we got some news this week about
that live-action Star Wars show that
we've been talking about that's coming
to the Disney streaming service we
officially have a writer input and
producer in Jon Favreau which I think
it's pretty good news I mean he's
obviously someone that Disney has been
going to a lot lately he directed The
Lion King the live-action jungle book he
has some writing credit with the solo
story with the Han Solo movie coming out
right now so obviously he's had some
experience he does some good things
directed Iron Man so we know that he can
kind of write and do this kind of thing
well and I think it'll be most
interesting to see what exactly this
shows gonna be about yeah who exactly is
it going to be about maybe since he's
had some writing with a solo movie maybe
it'll be about young Han Solo maybe
you'll be about Lando Calrissian Lando
the Lord or a super Turner maybe maybe
we get I'm just yeah we have no
information about when this is coming
out or even still the name of that
Disney streaming service but it's coming
it's happening it's in the works that's
right also this week we saw some leaked
footage and pictures from the set of
says I am the movie and the footage kind
of showed a little bit it seemed to
marry like comedic which we kind of knew
was going to happen because you know
which is Sam but also it showed
Shazam kind of like helping people out
of the bus like a burning bus I'm
guessing and it seems
silly it was of course a guy who like
worked at a building that was like 10
stories up though so we couldn't exactly
see a lot of it but that's sort of what
it seems like they're going to go with
for kind of the tone of the film and we
did see some closer up pictures of the
costume these are far from the official
release of the costume so they're not
touched up they don't have any of the
effects that we would see on the final
version in the film and I would I would
say that shows so it looks very similar
obviously just straight off the page
right however those muscles man so that
padding it just looks very like he looks
sculpted but he looks like literally
sculpted out of them film you know I
mean I'm not too worried about it yet
but I'm not the costume person you were
too worried about it yet because I think
they'll do some things to it and post of
course and with the big muscles I think
it kind of looks like how Alex Ross
would draw the character lutely so it's
kind of similar to what I'm used to
seeing um I was more concerned about
that hair about the hair looks super
plasticky mins off now I will say that
it's it's very very much comic-book
accurate and they've taken they've got
some really cool details that fabric is
lovely don't get me wrong and it just
seems very thinking very much like that
plastered hair look now if Billy the Kid
just thought of this as his ideal like
what a superhero should look like I can
kind of get behind that as like a
storytelling perspective right I could
kind of see that but he definitely does
not look like he should stand next to
Superman
that would be strange right the tones
would clash she's always been kind of
like can't be absolutely yeah so if
that's the tone they're taking you might
as well just go for it
I guess I'm surprised though that a lot
of people take a lot of liberties with
costumes and this was the one they
decided to do so accurate yeah the
comment box so good job guys but I'll
wait to see what it looks like
later I'll try to reserve some of that
we can look for that in April of 2019
yeah yeah also this week for DC news
Wonder Woman to has its villain that's
right it's been in rumors that Kristen
Wiig was possibly going to play cheetah
but it is now officially confirmed she's
gonna play cheetah
so that means chillin yes so it doesn't
mean that she's the only villain we
don't know anything else story wise
however I will say I'm very excited for
this casting Kristen Wiig is fabulous
actress I for one love her and I think
that just because she's a comedic
actress doesn't mean she can't take on a
more serious role and we also don't know
the storyline so maybe something more
comedic and out there makes more sense
for the story this time you don't really
know I'm a little unsure about the
casting not because I don't think that
Kristen Wiig could play something like
this I think she's a fabulous actress
but we've seen her mostly established as
a comedy person as showing comedic roles
and my concern is then that they have
someone who is specifically comedic so
then they can turn Wonder Woman to into
more of like a guardians of the galaxy
thor ragnarok feel which I don't think
fits with the first wonder friend so I
hope it's more of us testing Kristen
wigs
acting chops out rather than it turning
into a fun high jinkin comedic thing I
doubt that's where they're gonna go with
that yeah but we don't know it could be
I would say Shazam is kind of geared
more towards that kind of general I ever
knew hopefully yeah that would be what
makes the most sense yeah
also this week we had an exciting
announcement from Nintendo Super Smash
Bros is coming to the switch and I
personally a very excited I am ready for
a Super Smash Bros on the switch I liked
the kind of teaser trailer that we got
with it definitely confirming that the
Inklings are going to be a part of the
lineup here because that's how it starts
with a female and male one
you know fighting with the incan etc and
then all of a sudden turns around and
there's the reflection of the smashball
and in her eye and it's revealed but the
whole cast is standing there in shadow
so go ahead Internet keep telling us or
speculating about who you think else is
going to be in this lineup
there's definitely Bowser totally about
shadow in there and then we got a very
definitive Mario and breath of a wild
link make sense yeah yeah but it'll be
nice to maybe get some of those
interesting weapons as a lorry of the
smash characters as well we don't have
any release date for this yet just 2018
but I'm very excited maybe once it comes
out you know have a little bit of a
Smash Bros tournament you know when I
mean Walter is not busy fighting his
duplicates or whatever's going on over
there a giant Smash Bros tournament
maybe maybe talking for a little while
about the Mario movie they're going to
be coming out by illumination studios
and something happens this week that is
making me super concerned about that
which is we got a trailer for the Grinch
also by illumination studios Oh yen's it
was a thing that happened in I'm really
not too excited about it I thought it
just looked so childish which I know
it's a child it's a children's book it's
going to be a family movie but you can
do something like that without having
stupid humor like it was the whole
opening sequence was him trying to shut
off his alarm which was happy happy
happy okay as a nanny though who's had
to listen to like the same song a
million times I get that feeling you
know it was a whole thing where he threw
a book at it yeah and that wasn't enough
okay but benedict cumberbatch yeah I
liked his voice yeah I will say max
seemed thoroughly happy to be serving
the Grinch instead of like being and
oh yeah you don't want animal cruelty
maybe I don't know did seem like a happy
does makes lattes Browdy these lattes
I'm gonna drink a frowny-face latte it's
not like up to like foodservice code but
that's cool I'm a bad dog um I will say
that um what is he wearing
it's like the Grinch wears like a body
suit of his own like body fur which is
like the equivalent of me wearing like
not just skin tight leggings but skin
leggings little human flesh right shorts
right
yikes that's a circle that's a stupid
thing they threw in there just to be
like oh he's wearing underwear no you
can do it without having that Oh anyway
you're gonna see it no okay well you
couldn't see it or not see it on
November 9th your choice your choice
it's up to you also this week we got to
reminisce on something else from our
childhood which was from the trailer for
Christopher Robin which hot take I liked
little creepy okay fair but I liked it I
liked the look of Winnie the Pooh it
here's why
opinion time I think that I'm thinking
back on some of my most cherished and
loved stuffed animals and they got real
gross after a while and we knew the Pooh
is a stuffed animal first off did you
want like a tiny little bear cub no did
you want to have some weird 3d like
animation cartoon like no I just I
really liked the look of Winnie the Pooh
I didn't find some creepy as many other
people in the studio David's time but I
didn't I thought it was very like at the
moment that he says Christopher Robin I
was just like I think it'll be
interesting to see if when they go back
to the Hundred Acre Wood
there's going to be like a revival of
him if he's gonna look like brand new or
all the care I'm gonna have this weird
worn look to them because then it would
total it looks like a horror film it all
of the characters are like a little
Burton II it and Burton okay yeah I'm
interested to see what the rest of the
host of 100 Acre Woods looks like yeah
we've got a real rough a or who's
already rough around the edges you know
we'll see but I don't what we'll see but
I liked the trailer it was it was very
cute made me think I was like hook very
excited anyways let us know in the
comments down below what we missed from
this week we only have so much time here
otherwise you can let us know on social
media Heather where's that for you
you can find me on Twitter at Heather
ruse Instagram at a truce and twitch
twitch TV slash other ruse and you can
find me on Facebook as Iona Wade or
everywhere oh it's awesome
Ayana and we'll see you tomorrow on top
5 for more ethey hashtag where's Walter
saga because hashtag revolt is back
otherwise we will see you here same time
same place
in the meantime beam us up
[Music]
[Applause]
you